The distance a person can see on
a clear day is estimated by
the formula v is equal to 1,225
times the square root of
a, all of that over 1,000,
where v is visibility.
So that right there is
visibility in miles, and a is
equal to altitude.
Fair enough.
Now, they say if Jerome can see
for 150 miles-- so that's
how far he could see; so that is
the visibility, that is v--
about how far above
the ground is he?
So they want to know what
the altitude is.
About how far off the
ground is he?
This is a.
And this is what
we don't know.
We know that his visibility
is 150 miles.
We want to know what a is.
So we could look at this formula
for visibility as a
function of altitude here.
We know what the
visibility is.
It is 150 miles.
v is 150 miles.
So we can say that v, or 150
miles, is equal to 1,225 times
the square root of a-- a is how
far above the ground he
is-- times the square root of
a, all of that over 1,000.
Now we can multiply both
sides of this equation.
We want to isolate this radical
here, so that we can
solve for it.
What we can do is we can
multiply both sides of this
equation times 1,000
over 1,225.
Let me scroll to the
left a little bit.
1,000 over 1,225.
And the whole point of that is
so that we can isolate the
square root of a.
This 1,000 cancels
with that 1,000.
That 1,225 cancels
with that 1,225.
And we get-- and I always like
to have the variable I'm
solving for on the left-hand
side, so let's put it there.
So let me just switch
sides as well.
So we get the square root of
a is equal to all of this
business over here, is equal to
1,000 times this 150, all
of that over 1,225.
And it looks like there's
some simplification
that we can do here.
Both of these numbers seem
divisible by 25.
This number up here, 150,
that's 25 times 6.
So let me write this.
This is 25 times 6.
And this number right
here, what is this?
This is 25 times-- let's
see, 12 times 4 is 48.
And you're going to
have one more.
25 times 49, if I'm doing
my math right.
Let me double check that.
49 times 25.
9 times 5 is 45.
4 times 5 is 20, plus 4 is 24.
Get rid of that, put a 0 here.
2 times 9 is 18.
2 times 4 is 8, plus 1 is 9.
We get a 5.
Get a 12.
Yep, it's 1,225.
So this is 25 times 49.
This is 25 times 6.
Let me cancel this.
Cross that out.
This 25 cancels with that 25.
And so, does it look-- you
know, 49 is 7 times 7.
So that looks about as simple
as we can get it.
So this is equal to-- we could
write it as 6,000 over 49 is
equal to the square root of a.
So if we want to solve for a,
we can square both sides of
this equation.
So let's do that.
Let me rewrite this.
So you have the square root of
a is equal to 6,000 over 49.
We want to square both sides
of this equation.
So we square both sides of this
equation and we will get
a, the altitude, that how far
above the ground Jerome is, is
going to be equal to-- well,
6,000 squared over 49 squared.
Or you could view it as 6,000
divided by 49 squared.
So let's figure out what
that number is just to
get a sense of things.
And let me get a calculator
out for this one.
I'll just get a calculator
out.
Let me clear it out.
All right, so we want to do
6,000 squared divided by 49
squared, which is equal to
1,400-- or, we'll round up,
14,994 feet.
This is equal to 14,993 feet.
I'm assuming that this equation
is taking our feet,
our altitude in feet.
They didn't mention it here, but
I'm assuming that in feet,
because that makes sense.
If you can see for about 150
miles, it makes sense that
you're about 15,000
feet in the air.